A pocas calles de aquí hay un gran
despliegue de policial intentando evitar
que cientos de personas lleguen hasta el
hospital donde se encuentra maxam Y esa
joven de 22 años que murió hoy como
consecuencia o después de haber sido
detenida por llevar supuestamente mal el
velo Y es que las versiones dadas por
las autoridades y los de la familia si
no se contradicen por lo menos no
concuerdan las autoridades dicen que la
detuvieron la llevaron a una estación de
policía donde habría sufrido un ataque
al corazón hace pocas horas hicieron
público un vídeo en el que supuestamente
se ve a la joven este no tiene audio
ella se pone de pie en algún momento le
muestra una de las policías como si
tuviera un problema en una pierna se
pone sus manos en su rostro y se desmaya
y esto concuerda con la versión que
ellos dan de que tuvo un ataque al
corazón sin embargo la familia dice que
la salud de la mujer hasta antes del
arresto era perfecta y las imágenes que
se han visto desde el hospital Se le
veían con un moretón en el ojo y uno en
el de los médicos han dicho que no
concuerdan con esa versión de un ataque
al corazón y también han dicho que
tenían moretones en las piernas esto ha
aumentado la indignación de la población
iraní al menos un sector de ella que ha
visto como ha aumentado la represión en
los últimos meses y ha visto muchos
episodios en los cuales esa policía de
la moral se ha comportado de manera
violenta en las calles hoy el presidente
Ibrahim raíz hizo un llamado a las
autoridades para que investigar a
urgentemente y con precisión lo que
había sucedido con esta mujer